you
[Music]
three are not to be that is the question
whether tis nobler in the mind to suffer
the sins and I was a very just fortunate
consequence to see him troublesome by
opposing end them to die to sleep to
sleep perchance to dream mother you get
the idea micromachine man he presenting
a genuine original class of almost video
things micromachines a lot of people
know me as the micro machine man or the
FedEx guy are terrible Testaverde from
Saved by the Bell or just that guy who
talks fast in fact I was in the Guinness
Book is the world's fastest talker and
so for the last 40 years if you needed a
fast talker I was your go-to guy is that
okay did you get everything you need I
mean I can repeat it again if you want
you sure you don't want to do when I was
12 years old I wanted to get into the
Guinness Book of World Records so I
figured the only thing I could really do
since I wasn't gonna eat a car or
swallow lead pipe was to lock myself in
a room and teach myself fast-talking and
I did that with the hamlet soliloquy to
be or not to be here's later I'm at this
party fancy California Beverly Hills
party and a friend of mine is trying to
pick up this valley girl he's from New
York and talking pretty quickly and she
looks at him and says Nick oh my gosh
are you like the world's fastest talker
and he says no as a matter of fact this
person is they called me over and I did
one of my little party routines they
could come up to pick a cup up to be
back difficult to pick up a club and a
guy walked over he says that's
incredible I'm a producer and I'm gonna
put you on a show I went on the show and
I did the fast-talking thinking that
would be it and all of a sudden the
phone starts ringing and I'm booked all
over the place and I managed to make a
living out of it I can speak as fast as
eleven words a second now I never do 11
words a second for TV well let me do
Peter Piper at eleven words a second
pick up to pick up up to feed not do pop
typically depict and you kind of hear me
going pop pop pop but that's really all
you're kind of getting but when you do
TV there's visual reinforcement people
see you and do whatever so I do about
seven to eight words a second that would
sound something like
did Peter Piper pick you Peter Piper
picked a peck of pickled peppers Peter
Piper now on radio I have to do it even
a little slower because you have no
visual reinforcement you're not seeing
me so that I do about five to six words
a second so it sounds something like and
that's kind of the secret to my success
because if you can't understand what I'm
saying they're not gonna pay me the big
bucks now the very first commercial I
did was the Federal Express commercial
it is to this day the most award-winning
commercial in the history of advertising
the final scene I'm sitting behind the
desk and I'm going you know Dave what's
the deal with the deal are we dealing
David to deal with Don if it's a deal
with Doc so I did the thing like 29
times without making a mistake and the
director said to me what are you like a
machine you never make a mistake I said
you want a mistake I'll give you a
mistake the next time so I said David's
a dork with dick Don and duck and that's
the take he ended up putting in the
commercial anyone named Dave the first
time I saw it I called this John it's
our little secret although I'm known as
the world's fastest talker I do not
choose to live by entire life in the
fast lane
sometimes I just like to take it all a
little slower but sometimes it's really
really good to be fast
[Music]
the paper airplane you folded in middle
school horrible design but I've thrown a
paper airplane 214 feet I'm John Collins
I am the paper airplane guy world record
holder for a paper aircraft distance for
the year we got the record was 2012 it
was you know one of the great days in my
life actually you know I look back at my
child being born in the world record
those are great moments for me
I named the world record plane after my
wife the name of the design to Suzanne
this is how you fold Suzanne you start
with the short side of the paper out on
the page and put it against the right or
not what you want to know that you've
got an accent after that is to take all
right straight down to the top of the
plane you fold the plane in half it's
just eight simple folds there are a lot
of different kinds of folding techniques
and a lot of different kinds of paper
airplane there's planes the boomerang
back there are planes that are made to
fly straight very far there are planes
that are made of stay in the air for a
long time
every great paper airplane distance or
time aloft has very accurate volt most
people want to know how I got into paper
airplanes and the reality is I never got
out of them I am curious by nature I
love math and science the cool thing
about paper airplanes is it's a way to
actually discover something real about
flight what most people don't know is
that we don't know the exact cause and
effect for lift every little paper
airplane throw is like a little science
experiment here's the laboratory right
here in your hand that you could use to
do real science teachers kind of don't
like kids to do paper airplanes it has
this bad-boy kind of renegade reputation
if they could discover that paper
airplanes actually are science that
they're doing science and having fun to
it I think that's an incredible
breakthrough paper airplane throwing
class yes I set the record for the
lowest limbo of 8.5 inches and 2010 very
proud of that my name is shir Mika
Campbell and I am a world-class level
dancer I'm originally from Trinidad and
Tobago
which is also where limbo dance
originated it was a dance at wakes to
symbolize entering from one life to
another now today is literally
everywhere I got into the art of limbo
at the age of fourteen my grandmother
was a limbo dancer
my mother was a little dancer and it's
only right that I will end with the
answer I have to carry on that legacy
not only for my family but also for my
culture as well physically I am very
flexible I do my daily stretches I can't
really feel normal stretches so I have
like create my own so where I would
really feel the stretching my legs
I get a little crazy sometimes for door
[Music]
in order to make it under 8.5 inches I
have to hold my breath in order to
contort my body to make it under the bar
at the same time I have to think about
my arms I have to think about my
positioning I move side to side just to
show that I'm so suspended I start to
move actually physically under the bar
and that's pretty much when I'm able to
let the air out and that's when I will
get up it's very very very hard to do
the pain that I feel during practicing
and pushing myself that comes with it
but that's one of the things that really
drew me to limbo it was something that I
couldn't do easily I love the challenge
me making it under this bar perfectly
every time
it means the absolute world I pretty
much limbo any and everywhere I've been
on America's Got Talent twice I've been
on The Ellen DeGeneres Show I've been on
The Late Late Show with James Corden
when I see people's reactions and how
appreciative they are of my ability to
do this is just amazing all right
I absolutely love them both I love
everything about it
people think that limbo was just for fun
for Trinidadians like myself is really a
big part of our culture I feel like
that's where my job comes in to really
show you this is more than just a fun
little activity
[Music]
vmx is a fast-paced sport from the time
that that gate drops until you cross the
finish line you're always thinking about
your next move as long as I can keep
those two wheels on the ground
I'm gonna be out there on that track
[Music]
my name is Kitty West an hour and I am
70 years old I am the oldest female BMX
racer in the United States I have been
involved in the sport of BMX racing as a
racer for thirty years now now I love
challenges and this was just another
challenge when I began racing BMX
there was no women's cruiser class I
worked with our sanctioning bodies and
talked about the fact that women want to
be a part of this
we now have thousands of women and girls
who race throughout the country
there we go 56 and over women 70 years
young miss kitty Weston now are sitting
in that's race lot more total points
throughout each year I will do anywhere
from 25 to 30 races and quite often I'm
racing much much younger women I've
finished seventh in the world in the 45
and over women's cruiser class I was the
oldest female to participate in the UCI
BMX world is just unbelievable this can
be a dangerous sport in 1993 I was
involved in an accident where after
falling off of my bike I broke my neck I
was told that I might not be able to
walk again
but within six months I was back to
racing and I have continued to be
involved in the spirit
[Music]
[Applause]
haha thank you thank you good right you
know people have asked me how long do I
plan to keep racing BMX bikes I tell
people age is nothing but a number and I
seriously mean that every time I get out
on that track I win and it's not about
crossing first second or third but it's
about having fun it's about the
enjoyment of being with others who
really enjoy this sport I want to
continue to enjoy life and this is a
part of my life
[Music]
[Music]
we didn't really have any fast actors
from Texas until he came along like I
could really believe my eyes I got was
in shock his hands like they were always
moving and it was like there was no like
thinking about where to put it it was
just like a non-stop just like put it in
he's off the charts he's like as fast as
a lightning bolt
[Music]
my name is troy griffith and i'm the
fastest cub sucker in the state of texas
my goal is to be the fastest cut backer
in the whole entire world
when I first saw tre begin cups tacky I
was thrilled kids on the spectrum are
always very passionate and very intense
on what their fixation is and he just
shined I mean you could see that he was
in his element he was comfortable he was
alive and he was just doing his thing
tre took it to a completely different
level he was doing it systematically
instead of just kind of for fun
and it was all about getting that next
best time what tre does in five or six
seconds takes me 10 or 12 13 seconds
we've learned not to ever discount what
he says he's going to do Sport Stacking
is using a set of 12 plastic cups and
you stack them in a very specific
sequence of pyramids and you are racing
yourself and you're racing a timer
it's a sport that you don't have to be
tall you don't have to necessarily be
able to run quickly as long as you've
got the 12 cups you've got Matt and
you've got a timer you can stack to me
it's just mind-boggling to see these
Dockers like trade his friends and you
can tell they're not even looking at the
cups that they're stacking it is all
muscle memory
I mean it's so fast when they get to
this level that the naked eye cannot see
it all when I found out that I was
having a boy of course I thought about
when I was a boy and playing catch with
my dad in the backyard and you flash
forward you know thinking about those
types of things with your kid out
but when Trey found stacking it's like
okay cool
here is a sport that he's into and it's
got speed I've always loved sports with
speed and it's got rhythms which make
him happy and I realized what a better
way to bond with my child than to learn
how to stock myself I get to stand next
to my son who's one of the fastest in
the world and stack with him and be a
part of something special
watching the two of them stacked
together are probably some of the best
moments I've ever had
our motto has always been the family
that stacks together stays together and
we'd go to these tournaments together we
traveled together we've made friends all
over the country all over the world I
mean it's definitely enriched our lives
you